hello
this is andrea from udacity
uh we're going to be talking today about
uh exploring the idea of going to
graduate school
or upskilling which might be more
efficient for what your goals might be
and i am going to admit
everyone
and give us a moment to
see if other people are coming before we
start
you can also uh mute yourself unhappy
to have you ask questions participate
we're going to be doing a couple of
polls so to
give you a sense of of how to make this
decision basically or
what you might be making the decision
from uh
and i will give it like one more minute
to see
who might be showing up and perhaps you
all could
let me know actually in this that would
be great
and i will try to see if i can see the
uh i'm always challenged with this a
little bit
technology speaking i was going to say
in the chat if you could let me know
where you're from and perhaps also what
you are studying
currently at udacity or maybe you've
graduated already as well
we have about six people in the room
with us
there's the chat so
in the chat if you see the chat if you
could just let me know where you're from
i'm uh my name is andrea mia
and i am from or i'm living in portland
oregon
and it's all pretty wrong lovely
okay i think we will begin
so as i said my name is andrea mia and i
live in portland oregon
i'm a certified coach my background
actually is that i was in the film
industry for about
17 years or so doing producing
and representing films selling films
licensing films as well
mainly independent teacher films and
also some documentaries
and then i turned to coaching a while
ago and worked with the mba
program at unc chapel hill
and i have been coaching mainly focused
on creative people and
executives and now on techy people
and um and so anyway i'm one of the
coaches at udacity
and really happy to work with the
population there
okay so graduate school
so today's agenda we're going to talk
about
reasons why you might go to graduate
school both the questionable reasons
and potentially some good reasons
what some of the goals should be in
going to graduate school as well
and for some people hi doug nice to see
you
um and for some people uh whether
this might be as part of a bigger plan
to study abroad
and we can talk about that a bit as well
and then alternatively
the question is do you need grad school
or what your goals might be
and is upskilling going to be sufficient
and when we say upskilling
what are some of the options to get
experience
basically not um not just take classes
basically
not just take classes i don't know how
to set this up that everybody just gets
admitted but we'll
see how i do here
give me one second
okay okay great
so we're gonna actually uh have a little
hole
to begin with and
the pole should show up
for a second here launch polling
um what are some of the reasons that you
might be wanting to go to grad school
i think the polls should be showing up
on your screen right now
if you could see if there's any uh
reasons on there that you would be
interested in going to grad school and
just click on it you just get one vote
um that would be helpful and i'm going
to explain
one of them to you okay paper collecting
this is a particularly female thing to
do on some level
and men do it too but it's this
idea that i need more papers to justify
my life
and to have the confidence to present
myself
i need to collect these papers
certifications
on degrees and so on um this is a real
thing
i i'm definitely i've done things like
this myself
um so paper collecting um you know
you can be honest with yourself as to
whether the part of the reason you're
thinking about grad school or even
getting certifications
is because of the need to collect
some good reasons here some interesting
reasons here
um
you kindly mute everyone yes i can
kindly mute everyone
i think give me a second here
okay i think everybody is muted now
okay so thank you so actually the only
one that pulled ahead basically was the
challenge which is interesting to me
um because there's no reason that we
shouldn't have a challenge
and i think that that's a wonderful
reason actually
okay so now
um i'd like to do another poll
actually and
talk about these reasons here uh
could it be that you're thinking about
graduate school
because you think that a graduate degree
is necessary for your next step in your
career
meaning not that it is you've been
you've you've done the research and
you've figured out that it's necessary
but you think that it might be
you want to make a career change but
you're not quite sure
how you have always been
curious about something x y or z
you don't like your current job or you
don't know what to do with your life
or perhaps you are avoiding having
difficulty
and having difficulty in your um
your your job search
okay i just wanted to show you from the
last one what the results were
and then let's see
and then i would like to see if any of
these reasons
that i've just listed above here are any
of the reasons that you're thinking
about grad school
[Music]
okay so i'm gonna give this another
moment here
as i figure
[Music]
okay so we have
50 50 i don't know how they do this
exactly i think i'm gonna end the
polling
so four out of eight i guess
chose between you don't like your
current job or you want to make a career
change but i'm not sure how
and then you've always been curious
about x y or z
and then the other one's not not quite
as popular so i'd like to talk about
these for a moment though
because in some respects these are all
actually not really great reasons to go
to grad school
okay um you think that the graduate
school
is degree is necessary we'll talk about
this a little more later but
you need to know is it necessary or not
um obviously if you're going to become a
doctor
a lawyer a um a veterinarian
an anthropologist you know somebody in
academia absolutely
graduate school is necessary these are
part of the credentials that make it
possible
but for some things it is not necessary
and
so that is that is part of the research
that you have to do but certainly never
to show up
at grad school when it's not necessary
and make that whole
investment unless you have a series of
other reasons why
so i happened to go to grad school i
went for film producing
truth is absolutely no reason i had to
go to grad school for film producing
was it a good investment not sure jury's
still out maybe
um the networking was the reason that i
went there and because i want
and i study in a particular way and that
would be useful for me
but it is not necessary for the
profession that i went into
at all it like many other things
is a portfolio profession basically
meaning you justify your existence by
the experience and the work that you do
not by the degree
that you might need to get
um the other
one i just wanted to touch on here
is uh the reasons why there's these are
all like not
great reasons basically is it's a big
investment
if you don't have a clear plan as to
what you're going to do with it and why
you're doing it
in the first place just because you want
to change your job and you're not happy
with your job or you're not happy in
your life right now
or you're just having difficulty finding
your next job
and i know we are in the season of
covert right now where
perhaps some of you are not having jobs
and you're like well maybe i should make
use of my time in some other way and
upskill with graduate school and fill
that
because i'm not finding work right this
moment i would just question
whether again this is a degree that's
really going to move you forward and is
necessary in some fashion
and it whether it's worth the investment
because
it is a big investment potentially even
if the grad school itself is for free
you've got to live for one to two years
you know it's somewhere and and take
care of your life in that way
and if money is non-issue money's a
non-issue
but it's a consideration for most people
obviously
just sharing the results with you
okay
so the next slide is showing um some of
the reasons why
that might be good to go to grad school
it's absolutely necessary for your
profession it might improve
your career a graduate degree
may open certain professional options
that wouldn't be open
otherwise you have a very curious
and you just this is a good way that you
study
and perhaps you want to be a thought
leader and that
plays into a little bit the collecting
papers issue right
but um you could potentially be a
thought leader without that but there's
there's a certain platform that graduate
school or
having a phd that in fact gives you
that you might not have legitimacy
otherwise basically
so i want to talk about some of the
practical reasons also that you might go
to grad school
and this one i touched on a little bit a
moment ago
learning style and i'm one of these
people
i learn best with groups of people
i'm a bit of an external processor
basically
i like the formal nature of education
the showing up to classes at certain
times
and and connecting with people on
classes
that's how i learn best one of the
things you can think about
about yourself is when you have uh
in the past learned something and it's
really
stuck in some way like you really
got it in your system was this something
that
you were in a class for it was a formal
situation
or was it something that you delved into
yourself
deep and by yourself
if you can learn in that second way
easily great there's no necessity
to go to grad school in that way you can
do that type of work yourself
if you weren't look excuse me if you
learn better in a group setting
that could be enough reason that if
there was a subject matter that you
wanted to take on
and that was useful for your career in
some fashion
and you had the choice of graduate
school or doing it on your own in order
to get this information in your system
acknowledging that you learn in that way
might make it worthwhile if not you're
beating yourself up
so uh networking extremely crucial
probably the reason why
you pay for any of these degrees almost
more than the knowledge itself
that you're getting which is what is
that network going to give you
of your peers and of the professors
and of the the institutional
network itself the the alumni network
basically
itself that is probably
the number one reason why you should
think about going to grad school
and more importantly
one of the biggest priorities of what
you should
get out of the experience also and it's
not the thing that you're
you know i'm getting an a in this class
or that class whatever you know and i'm
being able to do these types of projects
and i'm learning how to research and i'm
learning how to code
all of these things are fantastic
they're all skills
um at the end of the day i talk to
people all the time
who are just graduating from school
or have even been out for a year or more
and i'm telling them the same things the
things that you're supposed to take
advantage of in grad school
are the peers around you the alumni
network you have and the professors
and the access that it might give you so
that you become
employable and becoming employable is
not only being able to do skills but
it's being able to
have referrals have people say hey
joe is a nice guy to work with joe's a
nice guy to work with
is worth the 50 000
that you might you know put into
graduate school
if it gets you a job
without that part of it joe's a nice guy
to work
with you're you know you're more of a
number like everybody else basically
it's the same situation
all the time i'm seeing that people are
not recognizing that
the human connection in getting you to
the next step
in your career and getting you a job is
absolutely 100 crucial and it's how most
people
get work so i cannot emphasize it enough
obviously i've just emphasized it quite
a lot
okay um and the other thing is
uh the availability of the coursework it
may be something that you need to study
that is not uh available otherwise
other than in grad school so one of the
options
is also going abroad for school um
i'm sure that it can be tempting and i
just want to talk about some of the
issues to think about with regards to
this so
when i say abroad i'm going to talk
about abroad in two different fashions
um people who are outside of the united
states
let's say and who want to come to the
united states and
get a graduate degree and therefore be
able to especially in stem
programs be able to stay for a few years
afterwards
and work and have that experience in the
united states
and also people from the united states
who want to go
to europe potentially to get a degree
um which doesn't maybe cost anything
although it does
obviously cost for living there
um or people that are in india and
want to they know they want to get this
degree
from somewhere in the united states and
go back to india for example with it
because that gives them a certain
prestige going back
that way so there's a lot of different
when i say abroad there's a lot of
different abroads that could be
at stake here um
so and and some of the considerations
you need to make
are if i'm going to go and get this
graduate degree abroad
where do i eventually want to be
do i want to go and get the degree in
uh in europe let's say and i live in the
united states and come back to the
united states
and i'm hoping that that credential and
that
um that prestigious thing over there
translates over here
the question is does it okay does it
carry the same weight
as in and it doesn't carry the same
weight as if
you stayed in the same area basically
that you went to grad school and that's
part of the question you need to ask
yourself and also the opposite i'm
getting a degree in the united states
but i
really want to go live in europe have
they ever heard of this school before
um does any does anybody care about
are there any alumni you know in that
area that are going to help me
move my career forward when i want to
move to india or i want to move to
europe i want to move somewhere else
basically and i'm not trying to exclude
parts of the world i'm just trying to
say that
there's a lot of people who want to come
to the united states and get a degree
and then either go home or try to make
themselves settle in the united states
and there are
a good number of people that think going
and getting a
free graduate degree is a fine idea and
it may be a very fine idea but some of
the considerations you need to
keep in mind are where do i eventually
want to be
is this degree going to help me there
eventually
is it prestigious enough basically to
make a difference that people have heard
of it before
or not um i'll give you a little
personal story about this that is
kind of interesting and just in the
sense of sometimes it isn't what you
expect
so i went to a very prestigious college
but it's a college that not a lot of
people in the united states
really know about for some reason and in
fact it was a very confusing one
from when i came where i came from
in north carolina um the name of the
college was columbia university
and people thought oh that means you
went to school in south carolina
that means you went to school abroad in
colombia the country what does that mean
the responses i got were all over the
place
when i went to live in japan for a
couple of years
people absolutely knew what columbia
university was there was no question
about it whatsoever
my degree was more useful in some ways
as far as prestige etc outside of our
country
than it was inside of the country
just an interesting sort of story but
you wouldn't know it unless you like
start
delving into it basically and and
figuring out what
what are these um what are these schools
what are the reputations and where do
you want to be with the reputation
basically as well
okay so let's say that you decide that
grad school is something for you to
consider
one of the tips i wanted to make sure
that you know and
pay attention to is that you don't
choose a grad school based on one
professor
and their work and that you really want
to work with them over
everything if the department does not
have
enough depth to
um give you the education that you want
and be able to do the research
potentially that you want to do choosing
it based on one person
can be a really poor choice because one
they can go away two they can die
three they can change their area of
focus perhaps
so there's there and i and i have seen
this happen
way too often for people choosing a grad
school and then
the reason that they chose the grad
school goes away
so one of the things that you need to
focus on
if you have chosen grad school is really
creating a target list
you see what i've put out in front of
you as to how you would start breaking
down these issues
one of the things i wanted to to
emphasize was number
oh i just noticed i have two number
sixes um number six and seven
which is student contact details and
alumni contact details
i think these are actually two of the
often
not paid attention to and yet really
important things to do when you're doing
research into grad schools and to which
grad schools might be the appropriate
ones for you
and that is talking to current students
talking to graduates of the program
finding out from them what this degree
is giving them or has given them
how they've taken advantage of it in
some fashion basically or
was it not very useful for them in
other ways getting a sense of
even you know how engaged the student
body
is or the alumni body is how loyal are
these people how engaged are they in
their
their alma mater in some way this is
work to do
in advance as part of the decision
as to which college and which college
which graduate school
you want to go to and people don't
don't think that that's so important
they go off of oh i've heard of the
university it's prestigious
good enough right the department seems
good
that's good enough you know as i said
before
one of the most important things you get
out of it is networking
test it test their network see see if
it's actually
like useful and that people are engaged
in some sort of fashion
see that people are happy with what they
got out of the school as well
i think if you talk to people you know
that have
been recent graduates or currently you
get
currently in the school you get a better
picture of
not just what the work is about but
whether they feel
like they are getting a good that their
investment was really
well placed in this institution
the only way to find that out is not in
the literature and
not in hearsay but by actually talking
to people
so i will emphasize number six and seven
in that way
that that should be part of your process
of figuring out
what grad school would be useful to go
to
okay so let's say you decided okay
andrea you convinced me grad school is
not for me
i don't want to do that for whatever
reason okay
um what are the what are the
possibilities then
for upskilling yourself and for um
getting more training in furthering your
career in some sort of fashion
so i would say that one thing you're
doing right now and taking a udacity
class absolutely one of the ways to do
it and there are many other places that
you could possibly take classes
and getting certifications google has
just opened themselves up as a
university of
alternative basically um so there are
definitely different ways to get
many skills if we're talking about the
type of skills
that don't require um a grad school
degree like you don't it's not about
becoming an anthropologist for example
um there are many ways of gathering
these
skills projects and experience based
things that's part of what udacity gives
you which is fabulous i think is is
really
focusing on the type of projects that
are going to show that you can actually
do the type of work that um that you
if you're heading in that direction and
she'd been looking for projects
in different ways different ways that
you can do projects other than
classes obviously freelance work
doing an internship is another way to
start showing that you can do the type
of work that you want to go towards
and apprenticeship is another way of
doing that internship with
apprenticeship
depends on which country you're in and
what the setup is
but there are you know data scientists
there's a lot of people who are data
scientists in
in the general um udacity family
basically
and uh being able to show projects being
able to really step
into that space makes a big difference
when people are looking at you and
seeing how you were qualified
here is a list also i just wanted to
share with you
of some of the freelance sites that are
available online
and some of them are very focused on
specific things like you see the extra
fi
on the list there that's one that's
purely ai
projects and robotics projects
kohlrab tree is for probably not any of
you in the audience in the sense that it
really is for people who
have their phd and are wanting to do
research in some fashion
the others are really more focused on
work
that companies need to get done problems
that need to be solved
and they're looking for freelancers to
do them in one fashion or another
the other thing that the two on the list
here are both
project oriented volunteer experiences
that might be interesting for you to
gather more experience again
catch a fire in the united nations they
both have digital projects
that need work if everything from
front-end
development to data science to
um you know design work basically
anything that could be
digital that they need done these are
two sites to know about
that you could possibly volunteer your
experience
and mostly get more experience
for yourself um one of the other ones i
wanted to share with you
sorry this is a little whacked out there
is
also uh these are all different uh
ways of freelancing but being part of a
group
as well so these are all sites
that are freelance sites but let's say i
have a problem
that i want solved and i need a designer
a front-end developer a back-end
developer
and and maybe a data analyst to
put it all together basically and figure
out what my angle is going to be in a
marketer
what they're doing is they're putting
together all of those people
under under the banner of like co-match
in germany basically
so all of those freelancers work
together on that project
and co-match matches matches them all up
basically for companies so that's
another way
of getting more experience basically and
being on their rosters
okay so question is
do you have any questions do you have
any thoughts about
um this this uh challenge of figuring
out whether you should grab
go to grad school or whether you should
create a portfolio life for yourself
basically
um i'm going to try to unmute everybody
and ask that you ask questions and also
please
please do um share oh and the
question that akshat asked um
is will i be sharing this thing on like
it will be online i think within like 48
hours or something
so i will not be putting out something
yeah
go ahead uh so
i agree that going to class
and for me also meetups and things it's
more about the networking
so the problem is right now we're in a
situation
where physically meeting people is
very difficult and then you're taking
online classes
it's very difficult and i'm john furrier
are there ways around that to
[Music]
uh do a little bit more networking i
just don't know how people do it
so you're talking about when you're in
grad school basically
and then how do you solidify the
relationships with people
that are in your classes for example
yeah
like let's say i'm taking some udacity
classes um how do you network with
people
or you know just or just in general
because we're
we're in an age right now where it's
everyone's at home on zoom
and you know if you're going to some
place where you don't know anyone
it's nice you know to network but it's
very difficult
it has to be more intentional that's
what i'm finding with people
in in the sense that you're not going to
run into them
in the coffee line in the cafeteria
right now
that's that's taken out of the equation
so
it has to be even with udacity students
uh one of the things i think is
that is missing when people are
connecting is they're
like connecting on linkedin like be
friends with me on linkedin
and that's to me it's like
collecting flowers you know that are
eventually going to die and they were
pretty for a moment maybe
you got no value from them particularly
i think that the only way to to actually
start solidifying the relationship is
to look at it first of all as a
relationship look at networking as
relationship building
you're looking for people that you have
something in common with
that you can create the connectivity
maybe they like soccer and you like
soccer
maybe they're really interested in the
same subject that you're interested in a
lot
and you want to share that chitchat it's
not
really it's that's right
no no it's it's actually but but
doing informational type conversations
with people to begin with getting to
know them
getting to see let them know use
something about you as well
um what i'm seeing is that a lot of
people
are doing that on zoom basically or on
google meets or wherever
whatever platform and they're requesting
time from each other
to sit down and get to know each other a
bit
that's what i mean about the
intentionality you're not going to run
into it just randomly
you've got to make educated guesses and
say
okay this person actually kind of looks
interesting i don't know why but it does
look interesting
now i need to do some outreach and find
out if we can connect on a deeper level
um it's really
it is it is time and work and that's why
i'm saying it's like
it it's not going to come so naturally
now
the other thing is that like my my niece
right now
is um about to start uh graduate school
at uva
and i they're not going to be entirely
online and a lot of grad schools are not
going to be
entirely online basically um and the
other thing is that i've talked to a few
professors now
who teach grad students and undergrad
students
and they've talked about this this
this issue as well and one
one history professor friend of mine was
saying that yeah he's going to be doing
a little more group work
so that they can interact with each
other basically online so they're going
to have
projects that they have to work with
together and so this is going to be the
way they work together most probably
um and that will give them the
opportunity to start developing those
relationships
and as i was saying with uva they're
doing some of the classes are going to
be in person
and some of the classes are going to be
online depending on the size of the
class and how they can break it up
um but it's a united
it's st it first of all you got a bunch
of introverts
and then on top of that the work is
pretty much independent you know for the
most part
yeah it's not really a group work type
you know thing basically so you know you
already have like two strikes against
you
and then you have the third strike and
zoom and it's like
coveted and it's terrible you don't say
they do i think um
i mean i i think what you're bringing up
to some degree also is a mindset
issue and not that all introversion is
mindset
but um that
developing a trying to work on a healthy
sense of curiosity
about other people um and
not asking the how are you question you
know that's sort of a meaningless
question in a way in a lot of ways
but what excited you this week
you know what was interesting that you
learned this week
asking the more engaging questions
um yeah to bring i was with one guy from
switzerland
and i just remember now i'm recovering
from a
heart transplant and one of my dreams is
to go to get back into skiing
and skiing with swiss alps so maybe i
should just ask
them absolutely i mean this is
you know one thing to remember is that
these are people
that's all they are i mean you know
there are people with different
interests and different experiences
and and it's not all about networking
around
professional stuff it's about connecting
in different ways
and so yeah that you want to you know
get back into skiing again someday
and maybe in switzerland um and what's
the latest and greatest over there
you know that's a wonderful way
wonderful one
i'm not diminishing the difficulty of
networking
and the overcoming the shyness
i'm just saying that there are different
tactics that you can take
and most people feel uncomfortable about
networking
because it is it feels like it's about
taking from people
i want to i feel like i have to put work
into this like i'm going out dating
like normally i break the ice i just
have them talk about themselves
and they talk about themselves they
always have something to say
that can work uh you've got to share
something about youtube but
it's i you know actually that's not a
bad attitude about the networking also
um in the sense of looking for
a way that you can help others
you have these resources that you have
you have your intelligence you have the
connections that you have you have
different abilities you know looking and
you never know
what you have that could possibly help
somebody else but
having a little bit more of that mindset
of
what could i do for others and
i'm going to cultivate curiosity about
them as well
i think makes for the beginnings
of networking which is networking it's
very much
the beginning you know of a relationship
um it can move that relationship deeper
faster
any other questions from people i see
ashka ashkat
has written me and i can't
seem to get to the chat easily
oh shoot um
[Music]
oh it's so good he wrote that to people
wonderful
so you're looking to change careers to
another field
how do you get around the problem of not
starting from scratch
in the latter career like going into an
entry level job
given that you have six to seven years
of experience already
it really depends and sometimes you have
to be
willing to somewhat start over
um here's some of the ways that i know
to
have that not be the case necessarily
one is of course cultivating the
experiences that are going to
like we just went through on the
upskilling list that are going to show
that you have the capability of bringing
value already to a given job
what is work about at the end of the day
work is just
problem solving and people giving you
money
because you can help solve their problem
the more you
feel like you are capable of doing that
as opposed to them
needing them to invest in you before you
can bring them value
and that's basically what an entry-level
position is
that they have to invest in you to some
degree to get you up to speed
the more you can show that that is not
the case the more you can possibly pivot
to a higher level and so one of the
one of the things to consider when you
are doing a career pivot
is how can so let's say that you wanted
to be a you're a software engineer and
you want to become a data analyst i'll
just
take that one okay um something to
consider is okay where were you a
software
software engineer where was it in the
healthcare field
was it in finance was it in was it in um
i don't know web you know certain pet
stores
whatever okay um
one way to pivot is try to stay in the
same domain
so i'm going to be a data analyst now in
the healthcare industry
i've had six to seven years in the
healthcare industry as a software
engineer
i know a lot of what the concerns are
that people
have especially in this area of
healthcare that i was in
how can you bring that value basically
to your next job
um you can if you can see where the
connectivity is and you can
share the connectivity and therefore
show that you have value coming into
them already because of the perspective
that you
uh have developed being in their domain
already being in their
area already so that is
one thing to consider oshkosh does that
does that make sense
to people it's hard to know everybody's
muted again
so um but yeah domain
staying in the same domain is a big one
um
showing basically that you have the
experience that you have the abilities
you also have to be careful not to
overself their new abilities i was
talking to somebody today who
has been in it for 20 years
um and he wants to move more into the
cloud
as if that's a huge change in some way
well he hasn't really worked in it yet
but he said he's familiar with it and
people are thinking he's an expert
in this because it's all lumped together
with his i.t
experience so they think that he's had
years worth of experience in the cloud
but he doesn't and so part of the things
he has to answer
is okay how do i show that i have this
value anyway you know
do i do projects basically to have the
confidence to be able to say
yeah and maybe i haven't worked in aws
for quite a while
but i do know how to work in it and i do
have this rich body of experience behind
me
to inform that i that i do it in a good
fashion basically
um so you can run into the other problem
which is
so what he was running into is either
he's looking too overqualified or it's
entry-level jobs
when he's really honest about how much
experience he's had with aws
he has to find he has to find more the
sweet spot basically
um being but able to show that he has
value
and not overshoot it too much
any other questions anybody has do you
know
if udacity alumni
stay in touch through the system
um not entirely now there
are alumni like as there's a facebook
group
and a linkedin group and when you have
graduated
you should that should be something that
you ask the career services people about
basically um to be invited to
the uh so i will just share with you my
little experience with which uh
i chose because i was coaching somebody
who was interested in self-driving cars
um he really hadn't
met anybody who was working in the field
already and he was wanting to move from
goldman sachs to
move over to the self-driving car and i
was like well before you do it you
really need to talk to people
in this field and find out what sort of
skills beyond taking udacity's class
they're really looking for
and what are the options here and i
asked two people that i
happen to know that we're working at
nvidia and fiat
whether they would talk to him about
this and they were and i just said the
fellow udacity grad you know that's
that's all it is and they were more than
willing to do it
they were like thrilled yep great people
are asking me questions
wonderful okay so something something to
keep in mind is also like
that a lot of people are really willing
you just have to make that connection
with them and say hey i just did this
also
i see that you also did um this degree
i would like to and i and i might see
even more about you that
that's interesting i would like to have
a conversation with you
and and learn learn something from you
do you have 15 minutes
that we could do with a little zoom
conversation like doug and i were
talking about a little earlier
so i'm tempted to meet people through a
study slide
but i tend to work in spurts
and i don't know if i could if and
you know if we could keep up with each
other that way since
i'm working full-time as well so it's
hard to put the energy in
right when you're doing that well it's
hard
to find you're not just not you're not
on the same schedule
you know i can put an hour and then i'm
gone for a while
you know i mean i think that's an
interesting thing since all of the
udacity things are very much
self-paced um there are people who take
a
really long time to finish some of the
classes and some people are
pumping through these in a month and are
really really intense so
i think it's hard to know um with these
study groups
what you're going to look into that way
and what and you're probably very
consistent with other people is that
they don't finish everything in exactly
the time frame
that um is expected if there is an
expectation in that way in a timely way
i would say
so i don't know i i think that the study
groups is an introduction
and if you had a group of 10 people in a
study group
and you knew you were going to drop off
i would think about one or two people
that you think are interesting
and and then just pursue it outside of
that time
and solidify it outside of that time
thank you for sharing oh oh great
good job doug you're being an excellent
assistant to me right now
um you just shared the alumni group for
the facebook group and the linkedin
group which i could not gather
fast enough to put you there put out
there for you
any other questions does that help at
all by the way
yeah okay thank you for asking
does anybody else have any questions you
would like to answer
the question yeah uh what do you think
of
part-time grad school so you can say
work full
time but then do grab score on the side
if it's supported by your employer
your question was what do i think about
grad school if it's paid for by your
employer without
grad school i'm sorry what kind of grad
school is there
hot pot time okay you can work full time
oh part-time grad school on the slide
yeah so um i think it really depends on
what is the grad school and what is the
skill that you're
taking in and is that going to be useful
for you
or is it just that it's free and
therefore
well let me choose something i i don't
know if the question is the part-time
full-time thing whether that's yeah
let's say
it's it's useful and it's more about
time commitment
maybe um
and what kind of grad school are we
talking about
um a good one no i mean i'm sorry
i meant like for example is it an mba
program or is it a
or is it a um like graduated say cs
major
oh okay um i don't know that it matters
hugely
in that way um i think i think that some
programs are oriented towards
your pod moving along together basically
and that
that pod work um is really crucial and i
don't know with the cs degree
whether that's the most crucial part of
of how you're doing it so if it was an
mba program for example
i think that that is more useful when
you do it um
either in one fell swoop you know or
with the same pod the same you know that
it's
set up as a part-time thing and you're
still a part of that group and you're
not piecemealing it together basically
um
with the cs i don't know that's the most
important thing
so that was no answer to your question
that was part-time full-time
either one could be great um it depends
on
basically whether you have the bandwidth
to do
something part-time and do work
full-time
um i don't think that networking-wise
or learning-wise
there's anything inherently better or
worse about part-time
full-time but your bandwidth is really
important to
think whether you can handle it
basically or want to handle it even if
you could
any other questions
okay so thank you very much for
joining today i appreciate it and
uh this will be up in about 48 hours i
believe online
and uh and good luck with your decisions
as to whether you want to delve into
grad school or we want to upskill
thanks
okay
thank you
now i'm trying to end this
you